People at home know
what a bump is?
probably not everyone
is like Coke no?
Me too. It's like
when a famous person
walks into the comedy club
and they get to go on
before you got bumped
by Jeremy Piven the other night.
Oh that's got to hurt.
No it feels good.
Yeah that's does have too like
someone famous in the crowd.
You're like (bleep) them
I do this for me.
And then the second
you see them in there
and you're like
I'm playing the hits.
Yeah. Like I hope they laugh at
me!
What's up everybody welcome
stupid questions.
I'm stupid Chris Distefano.
I'm here with my man
Sam Morrill. What you get
a good bombing story.
I always like to ask comics
Man I was in Bridgeport
Connecticut and it's going like
pretty rough first 20 minutes
or so that's Bridgeport.
Here's a guy
who's just heckling me.
Every other Joe
said Dude shut up.
No one gives a shit about your
stupid additions to my jokes.
Shut Up. Shut your mouth
and he gets up and I'm like
This is the biggest dude
I've ever seen.
Really started walking
toward the stage
and I'm like they're not pay me
enough for this so I'm outta
here.
So what do you do.
Walked off stage to boos.
I go in the green room
with a cordless Mike
I'm still holding the mike
and he's banging on the door.
There's like one woman
there doing security.
He finally leaves.
I go back out
and I do another 30 minutes
and then one guy right
as I get my rhythm back yells
he's waiting outside for you.
You know you do a shitty gig
when you have to plan
an escape route from the stage.
Here's a stupid question what
gives you a bigger sense
of accomplishment
clipping your fingernails
or picking your boogers.
Clipping nails.
Because then that means
that they got long enough
for me to actually.
Yeah I have anxiety.
Bite my nails.
Same. Same what me bite them
off to disgust.
It's not a cool..
it's not a good tock.
Speaking of Tick's there
was a guy just at a comedy club
and the guy had a tic
who owned the club.
he always says Mamma Mia every
time
he was like mamma mia! mamma
mia!
He kept saying Mommy and I
was like what's going on.
He's like oh I have a tick.
I can't control it mamma mia!
and just kept saying mamma mia
and then when he gets drunk
it gets even crazier.
You just he can't say anything
but mamma Mia.
it'd be great if the doctor fix
it.
Now all I can say
is Mama Mia too
Oh here's a stupid question if
you could be any vegetable
What vegetable would you be.
Terri Schiavo.
No I would be I would be.
I think I would be a pickle.
You would be a pickle
because they were allowed
in a lot
of different environments.
They're
a versatile veggie.
Yeah I think I get to be
zucchini or maybe a carrot
yeah carrot
to kind of they're another
like VIP vegetable.
You'll see him and like drinks.
Yeah. Get him in a cake.
dude your good looking guy.
Has anyone ever told you that?
You are really me now.
Yeah I do.
I got ecstasy
you've got do it.
Thanks for doing
stupid question.
Now you get a stupid gift
because you're special
is so dope positive influence.
I got you multiple gifts.
Most people get one
gift I got you multiple gifts
because you crush I can't wait
to see this.
Here we go. So we know
you're a big New York Knicks guy
but they're not a sponsor.
So we got you orange shorts
knicks colors and we got
this
is like a youth large
because you have little baby
bitch hips, um socks that we
got.
These are about 99 cents
for a 30 pack.
We got you a jersey that says
Knicks and Ewing.
But again neither our sponsor
can sue because it's not that.
And then finally just to
make you nauseous
framed picture of Joe Mackie
Oh god go look up this nut did
you have a good time on this.
I had a great time. Yeah I know.
Mackie you know
maybe put a damper on it
but hey it's been great.